Hello everyone, hello, hello, this is not pre, this part is not pre-recorded by, I am talking to all of you live, but hello everyone, hello, yes, a Sunday stream, yes, so, before we begin, I would like to say a huge shout out, and thank you to Nick Game,
and Level Infinite for today's sponsor, yay, so, in our celebration, If you guys didn't know, it is Nika's third anniversary.
So, oh my gosh, it's actually crazy.
It's been, I feel like, it's actually crazy.
It's been three years.
I, I can't believe Nika has been around for, um, Goddess of Victory Nika has been around for like three years now.
I feel like, I don't know.
I've been there since the very beginning till now.
No, I'm not pre-recorded.
I'm literally reading chat right now.
Mr. uh, what's your name?
Black Ninja VX11.
1-2-5.
I see you.
Hi, pre-recorded.
No, this is live, Jokey.
No, no.
No.
It's not.
You cannot win.
Look, you cannot win.
Dad.
Okay.
So, I'm gonna want to support the stream.
Please feel free to click the link pinned in chat or in the description below.
It really does help the stream out a lot.
But yes, again, a huge thank you to Niki.
um for the sponsor by the way uh like i said i will be showing a pre-recorded video um that was made uh for today's uh third year anniversary they basically invited me and a couple of other vtubers and to do a little something special in the i chat oh my god he left my room and then but he started shouting um in the kitchen um oh yes i was actually i think it was like Me and Snuffy were recruited two days before the sponsor.
So, like, okay, so I'll tell you guys, I'll tell you guys a story while we're watching it.
We will pause the video.
I was debating if I wanted to, like, go let the video play throughout it.
Or we'll pause, like, if I do, like, actual pure react, like, what's it called?
Like, reactionary content where I pause, like, try to make it more.
What's the word when you're trying to make it more your own content?
pause and uh start like talking about it like to make it more transformative i don't know if i should pause and talk about it to make it more transformative or we like just watch it all the way to the end so you guys don't get like out like like you know get taken out of um immersion or stuff we'll figure it out i don't know maybe i'll pause the video at some points because all of us are watching it at the same time i'm pretty sure they're already starting the video so i'm a behind already.
But yes, now you guys know why last week I was all over the place.
And I was all over the place.
And I was like so tired last week because it was like, I had two days to prep for this stream, this recording.
Two days, guys.
Because they're like, oh, we had some VTBs dropout.
Doki and stuff, you'll be able to do it.
And then at first, I was like, I don't know, two days.
And like, I don't have my VR stuff set up.
And then they were like, okay, but what if like you get paid this much?
I was like, let's do it.
I was like, what was that?
Yeah, of course.
I'm down.
I'm so down.
Yeah, I'm ready to do it.
I was like, sign me up.
Two days, that's nothing.
I can get all that set up so fast.
Yeah.
But I will tell you guys the story of how fucked up it was for me to prep for this stream.
But first off, let's just grab, let's get the video going.
I'm going to make sure I don't accidentally play the wrong video.
I need to make sure this is the right video.
wait give me a sec okay it's this one um all right sound guy i hope you're you guys help can help me adjust my sound you can type in chat all right if it's too loud let me know whoa by the way i am blind reacting to this so oh wait this is too big so i haven't seen the full edited version yet This is my very first time watching the full video.
Because they sent us the video literally like today, a couple of hours ago.
So this is my very first time watching how they edit everything together, how they piece it all together.
Can come, okay, video can, all right, there you go.
I lowered the volume a little bit down, yeah.
I assume this is related to the, it's like the third anniversary TV.
assume.
Spoilers.
Well, to be fair, I feel like new players wouldn't even know this spoilers.
Ha ha ha ha!
This is a spoiler!
It's a spoiler.
It looks like an anime intro.
Yes, I've lowered the volume sound gap.
Also, you can type in my chat.
You don't need to type in this one.
I know all these characters.
I've pulled for these guys before.
Also, you guys would not believe, like, which, by the way, I'll talk about when we're actually there, so when we get to the VR footage.
Hey, it's that girl.
Oh my god, it's that girl.
I know her.
I hate pulling for her in the game.
Name one character, Rapunzel.
I did it.
I knew it.
That's right.
in the you look that I can name multiple characters no no closing the door not loud inside anymore I'm doing a sponsor right now see Liberalia see I can name multiple characters look at that what's this red hood oh I know modernia I got modernia I remember we pulled for her describe Rapunzel she is a support character and she holds a staff and um she wears like this white angel outfit and um yeah that's right you want to test me again
yeah that's right you want to test me again you'll bet on it I know what Rapunzel look like
dang she got us there.
Nice tribe.
I know your rage pain because I know that's what Rapunzel looks like.
Don't mess with me.
Describe her personality.
She has really a big personality.
She has a very big personality.
That's what I can say about Rapunzel.
Told you!
That's right!
Don't mess with me!
I know my shit!
What color were eyes?
I know you guys weren't looking at the color were eyes, chat.
Alright, ooh!
Oh, third anniversary event!
I guess these are like all the new stuff that you can get for the third anniversary.
There's new side story banner, there's new rewards.
I assume there's gonna be like a lot of like freebies.
too like a lot of free pulls and a lot of like free i see 320 free recruits and ssr chime you know what you do you click on my link pinned in my chat and in the description guys to grab those free pulls right there yeah i mean all usually anniversary events they would have a lot of like you know they did to reward the players for sticking with them for so long um um they would tend to like give a lot of free stuff Wow!
She too has a very big personality.
Whoa.
I got to keep reminding you.
I was like, did you miss it?
Don't worry.
They all do.
Alright, just while, um, this is not the actual, we didn't pre-record this, but it's not our gameplay.
I assume, like, later on, you'll know.
I know the Niki engineers are very good at physics.
Aw, she's cute, and get her for free, too.
Am I eating?
I got Denny's last night, um, not this morning.
I woke up at, like, 6 a.m., and I got...
Denny's.
I was like, mmm, do I do I feel like shit right now?
Mmm.
I was just like, mmm.
Man, do I feel particularly shit right now to get Denny's today?
Like, sorry to hear that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I hit a new low.
I did.
It's not Asia Denny's.
If it was Asia Denny's, then that's just a regular day.
But this was N.A.
Denny's.
But I like how quiet you are.
What the?
Ma'am.
This is a battlefield.
This is...
What else?
Don't look at me.
Look at the enemy!
Ma'am, the enemy's in front of you.
Stop looking at me!
Oh.
Oh my god Who let this person into the battlefield?
Wow!
What is she even shooting at?
Downward die
Will thou be my guide?
I know you guys were not looking at her eyes chat Don't lie to me Don't fucking lie to me But it was the beginning and the end of fate's entwined.
I have long learned for the...
Oh, it just has to be the new story of that recorded a third year anniversary.
But I was sounding...
I hope all the... I hope the sounds been good so far.
At last.
The hour I have long desired is finally upon us.
Also, like, how...
How would we even see your eyes?
Yes, she was looking at us, but we were definitely not looking at where her head was.
I know the stories for Nikkei is always like really good too
Who's this guy in my Nikkei story You're not Nikkei Get out of here Not with your regular weird tiny ass gun
That's me Get out of the battlefield Let the ladies do the fighting.
That's my...
Oh yeah, that's John Niche.
That's literally him.
Exactly!
What am I doing on the battlefield?
I should be sitting in my base right now.
I shouldn't be part of this fight.
I should be sitting in my base commanding my women to fight.
by strong-ass women everything's so loud again there was never this much noise when mother was still here it was gotta or a fire I need to put an end to this I can't come out of being out there with them weapon to my G like my Bluetooth why Why can't I just Bluetooth command them from home?
I must have a shitty ass signal.
I still haven't regained much of my strength, which means I'm going to need the human.
The battery died.
Yet, as with all things, not proceeds according to one's designs.
I ponder, is it too soon or just in time?
As ever, we may do not but our best.
Okay.
Yo-han, must I really explain to you how huge a deal it is that we've captured a heretic alone.
A heretic?
Who's that?
That's her?
Call the monk.
Oh, Nayuta?
Are we calling Nayuta?
See, I remember their names, guys.
Suddenly, there are an awful lot of jests in Eden.
Hmm.
So this is the monk you kept running into when I wasn't around.
The one who never dies or something.
Does thou say that this which lies before me is truly...
What?
Fix her.
But only...
don't fix her can we actually fix her though i have many questions we can fix her guys
oh we're updating the new story
oh my god wait is that the end the one we definitely the downward dog
See, I can recognize her.
Only from the back, though.
Only from the back, apparently.
Which wandereth beyond the firmament.
And ever do I envision it?
Whether in waking or in dream?
The hour wherein that the curse of light shall be snuffed out.
Okay, but we never saw her front, guys.
She never turned around, chat.
All I'm saying is that she never turned around.
So I recognized her costume from the back.
That's all I'm implying.
And her beautiful eyes, too.
Guys, you're right, you're right.
Also her beautiful eyes.
Oh, it is in 3D.
all right what was the color of her eyes oh wait she's never mind can't test you oh wait that that might be extinguished once and for all that's the queen
oh she's so op she can here's like i might just have her only her as the team come forth my revered goddesses of victory if she can make loans of herself Why does it even build a team?
Just have her.
Now is the hour to rage or all.
Alright, I ate my bread.
Sorry, I had to have a little snack.
A little snacky break.
Oh my gosh, she title dropped.
You're right.
Why is this?
This was also...
This is not part of the recording, by the way.
I've never seen any of this before.
So I'm like, whoa, what is this?
Oh, that's so cool!
That's crazy.
Wait, did he not do any pre-sketches?
I don't think there's like any pre- like he's doing it all like actual no sketching at all.
But that's amazing.
That's insane.
Especially with like ink too.
Yeah, this guy's really talented.
Hey, no!
No!
No, I already...
But the lard looks amazing.
I think it's crazy that he didn't even need to sketch anything to just paint all of that without any like, like, uh, without any plans.
Like, it was just all in his head.
That's insane.
It looks so good, too.
You have to have, like, really good control with your hand to, like, ink paintings.
Now is the time.
As long as my subjects need it, I can clear the goddess' squad.
Title drop.
There was a pre-sketch.
I still think that's still really good, even with the pre-sketch.
Oh, guys, free code!
If you use goddess assemble, you get free stuff.
We all love free stuff.
We are the free stuff.
When the sun, it sounds nice.
It's not sick.
The crimson path will be my guys.
Oh, when you're in the middle.
Oh, poor change.
I guess it's a different character.
So they changed the music.
Music tempo.
And they went all out for the third anniversary.
I mean, too unfair.
Oh, I wish I could spoil the video.
It's just for the sponsor alone for what they did for us like what we had to do for this sponsor alone They went all out for the third year anniversary And this song is oh shit look at tyrant
I can't spoil it yet.
I wish I could I'll spoil it the moment of the moment you guys see it I'll spoil it.
I'll explain everything It was like, yeah, they went all out.
They all, they fucking went all out.
Niki always makes like, oh, we got songs and stuff too for the events.
Which is very smart too.
They could literally do a concert they want to based off, I mean, they have, they have done concerts based off of Niki music.
It's very smart to do.
Yeah, you loop it on Spotify.
Yeah, there's a lot of
chapters too.
Like, I mean, it's three years.
What chapter are they on now?
I would assume they have like enough for an orchestra.
Like an orchestral, orchestra concert.
42 chapters, yeah.
And every time there's a new chapter, they have to use like new original music too.
Cause there's always a big update whenever there's a new chapter.
Liberalia seized Eden's sphere and fired it into the sky.
Oh my god, this is it.
Okay, yeah, okay, I can say it.
They built an entire VR, multiple VR chat worlds for this.
Like, I've been holding it for so long.
I was like, oh my god, I can finally talk about it.
Yeah, so you guys can see, they built multiple VR chat worlds for...
For this event that we had to do.
And we were allowed to see, like, off the bat, what they were doing.
where like you know like all of it at once like they're like before the recording they're like all right we record this part and they're like all right next world and then so we got to experience it like as we go along and I would say I will warn you guys it was all one take as in like we do one kit take and then we're like all right next scene
yeah this is crazy this was all happening in the chat world by the way all of this was like in the vr chat world we didn't do pot in between takes like we'd be like all right pot cut and then next take and hey no oh there you go oh my gosh the whole ground is shaking what's happened oh it's actually impressive like she and i but you get to me i you know i was doing this one take
No, I can't do this alone.
I'm too weak against it.
I'm gonna need more help.
I need to assemble them.
Yes, she is assembling!
It's a kind of quiet.
I can raise it up.
Sound guide, try to raise it up.
I'm gonna raise it up anyway.
You can tell who can act and who couldn't.
As if you could tell that I was not...
I was not ready!
I did
Yeah, we're always like watching Yeah VTubers assemble Yes, we have to Bad guys, I'm so glad you're here It's kind of falling down Tudor Bao is a voice actress So Well That can't be helped Oh, okay, okay Awesome We're gonna get back together We just need a couple
Couldn't be
Okay, Snuffy was so good.
Wait, wait, okay, I'm going to feed Dad.
I'm sorry, I got to feed him.
He's going to keep barking.
He's he won.
He won.
He always knows what I'm doing.
He's sponsoring.
He always knows.
He.
Okay, no, Snuffy was so good.
Like, she did all of it one take.
She was so like you could tell that she plays VR That it was like I was like plus one RP, you know, but you tell she role plays
Pippa's here snuffie's here.
Maybe we have a chance.
No, it's still not enough What do we do?
How do we get the word out?
If only more could just miraculously show up.
I guess I'm here now, too
Now you guys know why I know who Rapunzel
Guys this is why I know I know exactly I know exactly what Rapunzel looks like I was like okay I didn't realize I was a like later on.
I was like, wait, I'm a healer.
I was like the healer of the group.
I didn't realize.
I mean, to be fair, looking at the costume, you would like, you would think, oh yeah, no, that has to be a healer.
I was just like, I wasn't thinking that.
I was a sound guy.
Should I up the volume?
Yeah, I was in support jail.
Everyone had a gun and I was like, don't worry.
I'll heal you.
the dps but you guys want me to a little bit up okay up a little bit no way is he a jokie the bird thank you so much oh right i'll i'll be sure to i'm not here to do it for free of course so oh yeah i wouldn't ask of that right right okay and then okay i i i Okay,
and then like Dokey the bird Okay, by the way There was one time We did two takes And it was because I was muted on the first take And then like everyone was like Dokey I guess I forgot to mute myself Because they're like Guys remember to mute yourselves When we're doing the intros I was like gotcha And then you know I haven't played VR in so long So I forgot to unmute myself.
So, um, so this was the one time we had to do two takes and it was just because I forgot to unmute.
And also, and yes to note, later, I didn't know who Rapunzel was because like, I didn't know what, because like I said, I, um, they hit me up like two days before the recording.
So I was like a last minute substitute.
of that i didn't know what character i was assigned to so they i was just like um they showed me like a screenshot and i was like oh that's so cool like we're gonna have costumes and everything and i didn't know exactly who i was until like we had later on you'll see we saw like pictures of who were supposed to be and then I saw mine and I was like wow I look just like her and then stuffy was like yeah but you're sort of missing like one or two parts I guess I could do it for a bit of a bargain you know what I'll take it sometimes the best also my full body tracking was not working I'll explain the rest of the story later.
Yeah, two very important parts we're missing.
I was like, I was like, I couldn't get it to work.
And then got my, I only got my waist to work.
Yeah, I was missing a little bit of some personality.
The pun's so deep.
It was a very, very strong sports bra.
Another really long weapon.
Yes, well, I mean, that's...
But I hope the sound is a little better.
up if he needed to yeah right where we're not gonna reach that i mean we could stack on top of each other but wow it's looking great we've really assembled the avengers we're just missing one more person.
I don't even know how to say that.
See-tubers assemble.
I think at that point I think I sat down.
That's why you don't see me.
I sat down because I was like, in frame I was tired I yeah yeah and head stood up yeah let's head to the war room to
oh yeah well now it's like whoa you're drifting I'm pointing this thing And then Louie's just like, wait for him.
Wait for me.
Yeah, support characters need a rest too, guys.
So the enemy knows we need business.
Bro, she's plus one RP plus one.
It's even worse than I thought.
The queen of raptures.
She's the entity that broke into our orbit.
But we do.
Her power abilities are far beyond our own.
I could take her.
You can tell I didn't know what I was a support.
That was the most...
I didn't know who I was.
I...
I didn't know I was a support.
I was like, I'm going to take her.
Yeah, I thought I was like a magician or something.
I...
Yeah, I was a magician.
very confident support.
It was later on I figured out.
In a fight, right?
I'm a front line.
Yeah, I'm a combat medic, guys.
Emphasis on combat.
Like I said, like, we were experiencing each world, like, for the first time for this, for this recording.
Yeah, I think so.
Somehow managed to survive the blast, but look at Eden.
It's gone.
Look at all the drugs.
Oh, no.
Just give me a deep end, guys.
I guess.
Guys, I think...
Guys, you think this looks bad?
I don't know about this one, Chief.
I got my...
But at least the monitors salvageable.
Oh, yeah, look, there's there's monitors still still intact My dove that way She's not okay You still look so intact
Let's get some reinforcements Okay, so this at this part at this part we we're just playing the story at that point what was funny was like guys um we want you to play until chapter 12 and then i was like what chapter are we on and then they're like we're chapter one i was like we're not getting the chapter 12 guys we're i was like and they're like to chapter for it and then like i was like i don't think we're even gonna make it
you can tell when i started sitting down too you can tell when i was like wait this is a long chapter
Don't heal her.
I didn't know I was a support yet.
I'm going to grab a chair.
Yeah, I healed the TV.
I picked up the television.
I saw other people sitting.
See, look, they were all sitting.
It wasn't just...
me so i didn't okay too bad i didn't know i could chief the staff until later
well so this is basically us experiencing the story for the like reading the story for the third anniversary chapter internal power sources as well as some underground generators nearby oh thank god and we'll be able to use it soon although It will only be operating at 50% of the time.
All right, I will be frank with you guys.
I read the briefing like five minutes before the recording.
But I have a very perfectly good explanation for it.
I'll tell you the story later after this.
But I'll tell you.
I was like, I was so messed.
Yeah, maybe it's worth sacrificing.
That would result in an...
Doki enhanced.
but most of eden's facilities have been destroyed do it try to secure maximum output there was a reason there was a reason too once and for all once and for all that's what i'm hoping for the queen is stationary right now also to be yeah i was so chilled i was so relaxed at that point i was just enjoying this story uh also like it even know i was on time for the recording but like we didn't start until 40 minutes later so it gave me time to fully read the work read the briefing see she can't move so easy vulnerable yeah yeah see the queen i was like oh the rapture is just in the sky we like she's not moving why yeah i was man's threat see i knew how i knew how to remove the staff here yeah or maybe there's some kind of malfunction
you're a big hat my big gun i think we got this yeah which is all bonker at the same time you're clearly having a good look at that giant ass gun i don't have that weapon also like Lumi, okay, the reason why no camera angle is like on the side to Lumi's model is because it is TOS.
It is like, it is not TOS friendly.
It was, no, she was not wearing much underneath.
I just let you guys know that.
So we had to like make sure the camera angle was just right.
And also like, I can't show it on stream.
but like I had in in VR in VR I had it so that like you know like in case like you know there's so many people in the uh in the world um I had it like turn the security the security section all the way up so like the model textures because like models won't like lag my VR headset so um because I did that the textures were like really like really like low quality and because of that I wish I could show it to you guys but I think it YouTube would say that's not TOS friendly but like bow's bow's left boob was showing but there was a hole like a giant ass hole where the nipple was and I was like what the I wish I could show it I like took a screenshot of it posted it to I think it's just like,
it was just like, like their lip boob was just popping up, but it was, the nipple was like the void.
I was like, what's wrong, what's wrong with your boob?
What, what's wrong with it?
Do not stare into the void.
I stared into the void and stared back.
Oh, bring up a little more.
Okay.
I did.
He's so edgy, though.
We were like...
We were just like making weird words.
Just like roasting the guy.
He was so edgy.
You know?
He was so serious.
Oh yeah, we started seeing.
our characters as we kept going.
Yeah, and then, yeah, and then, yeah, and then I was like...
That's when they showed Rapunzel, that's when I knew I was like, oh!
I'm here?
Yeah, I was like, what?
See?
Do you hear that?
Do you hear what stuff you said?
I'll rewind it.
I think you're missing a part of your character.
I'm thinking how you're missing a part of your character.
Yeah.
Just a little part of it.
And yeah, I still didn't realize I was a support.
I still didn't realize.
Yes.
I'm wearing a sports bra okay it's a very very strong sports bra possesses the wit to discern her machinations to decide her machinations yes young lady Dorothy is not at Eden presently I hear say she does reside within the art I think we're in the future Are we like old now?
That's not good.
Oh my god, we're like hags, yeah.
I'm dirty.
Wait, I just got nuked.
What?
La maidens.
Good one, past Doki.
We're on the same wavelength.
Thank you.
The super chat.
A supports bra.
Exactly.
I'm out here supporting.
that would be for the best let's leave right away it's gonna so heavy actually are you she's so like she's so immersed guys she's methodic acting now by what means
isn't she often ours it is the great hero thou speakest he is soaring through the skies upon the white giant at this hour RP.
You can't make heads or tails of what you're saying.
Let's go to the ark.
The queen will descend anon.
Anon.
Eden does prepare to intercept the queen.
Someone's having a good time.
Maidens.
What a polite thing to say.
We're just chilling.
What's happening?
Look up in the sky.
Is it burning?
It's it's getting dark.
Oh, Amazon delivery drones.
Oh, what a grievous flight.
What a grievous flight.
Guys, the sky is red.
That's a good thing, right?
Good one, Pastofi.
You're so funny.
I felt bad.
Red means good, right, guys?
I like this, Pastofi.
Wait, she's pretty big, guys.
I thought I said goddess fail Hell goddess
I can't believe it We're playing We're playing the game in VR God I'm so chill I'm so relaxed right now Yeah guys don't forget Forget guys because it's a third year anniversary If you use the click on the link right now uh you can grab all as especially if you're a new player you grab all the bonus pose there's like 225 free pulls right now that you can click with my link that's pinned in my chat whoa are we prepared for this hashtag ad what a deal last nicely destroyed
there's a big hole i'm fine too whoa what the heck happened we're not dead what the heck happened wait that's all we need are you sure can you confirm it again that we're not dead dude we're mobilizing and getting the shield I just need one more confirmation this guy is so I don't like him.
He doesn't fit my vibe, bro.
How do you know?
How do you know that?
I'm fired.
Let's go to HR, Pastor Oki.
Whoa!
Do not talk to her like that!
She is a queen!
He cannot answer you!
I might not be good at acting.
I'm sure.
five good one-liners the vibes were off yeah how he's talking
yes oh we're all safe heck yeah literally been wiped off still i don't feel safe and the forerunners have arrived i don't feel safe from that guy whoa this is danger danger they wish can it yet be called eden This was like, be quiet, women.
Oh, she's so funny.
Ha ha.
Oh, the pilgrims.
I got to us.
I was kind of disgusted.
Make yourselves at home.
Oh, like, we don't like each other.
Okay, okay, that's fine.
Awkward.
Are they fighting?
Do they not get along?
Yeah, we're beefing.
I will say, I can't react because past Doki already reacted for me i'm watching myself first time reacting to the chapter of nike and everything i want to say she's already said it so i'm just enjoying the enjoying the time pastor he was just too good like a re-acception i'm now a real streamer for like 10 minutes yeah i feel like she should have arrived by now yeah that's true is she going like 0.01 miles per hour or something yeah she's lagging servers are down she has like 300 ping yeah we missed the exit that the queen's vision was either greatly impaired or wholly unsafe i'll also let you guys know the reason why i'm always like fixing my headset because you remember when I tweeted how I was so proud of myself for cleaning my closet I also threw away my my all my contact lenses and then on that day at nighttime my manager contacted me and was like oh we have a last minute sponsor it's VR chat in Nikkei and I was like good and then I didn't So I had to wear my glasses Trying to do
it It was the very first time Yeah, it was very awful timing Like I literally I already threw away the trash I already threw away the trash bags And they were like I threw away all my contact lenses Because I was like I don't need those I'm like I should get a new I should get like New prescription for them anyway So like because they were an old prescription So I was like Oh,
I don't need those When will I ever wear contact lenses Because I haven't worn them in a very long time and then so so like you know obviously it was my very first time uh we're trying to wear glasses with the headset and like my glasses kept like touching my eye so it would like smudge the lenses so I always had to like clean my glasses like every like five five to ten minutes because I couldn't see I couldn't see anything because the headset kept pushing it against my eye
Yeah, no, it's not fun.
It's not fun having glasses on with VR.
Like, that's why I always had contact lenses until that day.
Literally a blind reaction.
She does linger.
I'm going to have a bingo sheet.
How many dots can we hit?
Take a shot.
take a shot from here now you guys know why i was like i don't think we're making it to chapter four guys like i was just out guys i don't think it's possible because this is this is chapter one and like i was going very fast like she was just clicking i'd like a tour of the facility what facilities it's gone Good one,
past jokie.
I'm like, what do we have left?
I will try my best to see that your requests are met.
I want meat and bread.
Very well.
Good job, yeah.
Good one, jokie.
I laugh.
I'm killing it, guys.
Could you stop being such a...
I'm actually...
Guys, you think, okay, wait, wait, let me...
Guys, wait, let me show you something.
Alright, uh...
Alright, where is it?
Oh, wait, did I save it?
Wait, did I...
Oh, no!
Wait, where is it?
Wait, I have to...
Okay, guys.
Alright, let me grab this.
I think it's pretty accurate.
I'm just missing one or two details, guys.
I think it was pretty accurate.
Look, I am a support player.
So because of that, I had to wear a support bra, you know?
I had to wear a sports bra to support it.
It's literally the same person.
Like, I was in a battlefield.
okay i had to wear that sports bra you've been starving i'll go check the infirmary and defense systems good pair up and show them around it's the same picture i'm
not sharing my food just so you know gladly i'm not sharing my fine isabel go everybody take off your shoes that's my request Don't worry.
Oh.
No shoes indoors, guys.
Well, I guess it is what it is.
I'm actually chill maxing now because like, I was like, I was like, we have four chapters to go through.
I'm, I'm fucking chill maxing.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Shouldn't we be figuring out how to get up there?
Hey, yeah.
Yeah.
How do we get up there?
I mean, we just wait for her to get down here.
That's true.
You know, a good point.
Why go up when she goes down?
Good one, Pastoki.
God, you're so good at this.
You're so funny.
How do you come up with this on the fly?
I'm counting on you guys.
Sorry to interrupt.
But considering the queen might fire another beam.
Because it's true.
She's coming down.
We have to make the effort to go up.
I agree.
We lose Eden Spear.
We're completely out of option.
It's also unlikely that the Queen can carry out such large-scale attacks.
It's hard to run around with those understandable.
Thank you for the super chat, Zero.
Thank you.
She's so polite.
It's also okay.
But that's all an assumption on your part.
What will you do if she does fire again?
If another beam does strike, we'll all die.
And that means our assumption was wrong.
And since we'll all be dead, we should just move it over here.
Thy words mirror those of young hero Johan to the letter.
You're right, I'm more aerodynamic.
See, I'm thinking about, like, I'm min-maxing.
We have a giant mirror.
We can reflect it.
Wait, physics.
We could use a TV screen.
Oh, true.
I'm so fucking stupid.
I'm so stupid.
Defending the Eden.
We put us in.
How did you put us in?
Great joke, Bastog.
Who's this girl?
Come on.
I didn't roll for you guys yet.
My bad.
Wow.
Oh, yeah, she wasn't even using us.
She was using girls that aren't even us.
Like, what the heck?
Why are we not showcasing this?
We're not better than them forever.
I can't believe this is our story!
We're the B team, apparently.
Already benched.
We barely benched.
Fated only to be an S.
yeah i know right i was like they're like vtubers assembled and then they don't even assemble us in like that didn't even assemble us in the actual game bandit thank you thank you can't wait to see the memes like to be putting up metal on to see faded only to be a minister we must needs prepare a poisoned chalice for that Oh?
A poisoned power?
YouTubers, disband.
Ooh!
We're gonna poison the queen!
The amount of raptures we're dealing with is no joke.
But we hold them on.
Disband it before it happened.
We are just the lore squad.
We're here to give exposition.
Oh, your hands are going.
Again?
Is that normal?
Is that- you do that?
Yeah.
There's- Oh, there's just frostbite here.
Oh, she's chilly.
There's no way to know.
All the more caused to doubt her trust.
That is why, er, any mis- We must need secure body bullet.
Monk.
I love the noise you're saving.
This was where at that point, the staff was like, okay, just spam click it.
We got it.
We got to keep going.
There's a lot more stuff we have to do.
Yeah, at that point, that's why you can tell the crew They're like, okay about just just keep clicking it.
We got to get move on.
We uh Why did she did she die?
Hmm, it's not bad.
Isabel now art adept in the arts of aerial combat.
I've got a short range weapon anyway Who do I need to engage in close?
I don't know
I feel so educated Anything else, honey?
You know why?
She was asking Bao Because they were like Okay, we're going to have someone Who has the most knowledge of Nike To do this part of the game So and then in the thing It was like It will be Bao because she has the most knowledge
fleeting what will you do once we defeat the queen what is this does so speak of the such speech may surely bring about one's demise just consider it casual well it is likely oh the music take a hoe you've done that already we're gardening why do you fight for human why don't you stop wielding your sword this does not constitute my sword feel like i won't have another chance to ask you this I desire to partake in drink with those whom I cherish you can drink any can't skip it.
We gotta consume the lore guys Guys, it's not just this by the way.
There's more to the recording.
There's more.
We're not going through four chapters guys.
There's more I swear to you guys.
There's more There's actually more to this world She's just chill guy She's just chill like that Does thou have a taste not really?
Oh Yes!
Yes!
Pre-gaming!
Yeah, can Nikkei's pre-gaming?
And we pre-gaming!
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, they just take diesel instead of unleaded.
Yeah, I was gonna say, can Nikkei even get tipsy?
I didn't know.
I didn't know if I was allowed to say drunk.
So, I mean, I said it now.
So, but trying to pre-record it.
I didn't know.
I was like, can Nikes consume alcohol?
Like, I...
So I was like, can Nikes get tipsy?
I was still trying to be very professional.
Yeah.
Yeah, now I know.
Now I know.
So now I'm able to say it.
at that time i wasn't sure i was like i was a little confused how do you plan on defeating the original queen up there tell me your plan i was so professional yeah pastor kew was so professional that's correct don't tell me no way you're not suggesting that we ally with eden to fight the queen are you disgusting is it better to increase our chances of victory even just a little no absolutely that's gross let's go rose why it looks so happy on the other side wait it looks so nice you know like the the meme where like one side's like you turn right and it's hell and you turn left just like like heaven good lord the plot yeah what is this coronation you speak of it's when one puts on the crown hmm so what you're saying is you're helping Marion become the Queen Marion why given the gravity of what you're discussing could you put a bit more thought into your questions we actually did not see this part of the game so This is new for me.
I'm just like, what?
I don't remember this in the recording.
Don't worry, the support is here.
Oh, it's Marion Mordernia?
Oh, that's the true name.
Because I'm tired of this.
And I'm disappointed.
Disappointed in the queen?
Yes.
Well, I understand she drifted through space for over a century because of an accident.
What accident?
That's not your fault.
The queen has become a coward.
She could have corrected her orbit and descended to the surface right away.
But she didn't.
Why?
Because she was afraid.
Why was she afraid?
Oh wait, no, she is still alive.
I know because I have Cinderella on my team.
These fears stopped her from acting.
Anyway, she didn't come down to the surface because she was scared.
I like to help her.
I think she needs all the support, guys.
That makes sense.
So I took it upon myself to make a queen.
Then I tried a little of this and that.
Fortunately, a queen came into being.
That's why I want to make Marion the queen, no matter what it takes.
And you don't want to be the queen yourself?
Yeah, I don't want to be queen.
It seems like you already have all the plans for it.
I'm nothing but a data-based life form with no corporeal body.
That's not your real body?
Form is just a mimic of the person whose personality data I'm based on.
Oh my, that's a very big personality, though.
The truth is, I want someone I can...
control to be the queen she was a nun back then that's right like me i can't say i i can't say anything if i say anything i have to go to confessional i have to repent if i say something
you are quite literally my bodyguard and my sword Isn't that what you'd call a puppet?
I prefer the term proxy.
That is not a nun outfit.
What?
A nun outfit is like baggier.
Like that is...
I think she got the child size of the nun outfit.
I'm fine for now.
Do bring some next time, if you please.
They're in my room.
spirit Halloween and bought like children's size that does not look very spy ish of her over where still out there isn't she gonna get some supplies she already came back twice each time she had a drink and went back out so alcohol is basically her fuel since lady Isabel have come I'll bind me here a spell and take my ease do you need supplies pray pour me a drink here I've warmed it up for you hmm something wrong no it's wrong warm spirits in the midst of battle it is indeed a rare luxury I shall partake most Gratfully,
Lady Papio.
Wait, what happened?
How did it get here?
Oh, that's me!
That's me.
It looks just like me.
Wait, it seems a bit low.
That thing is huge.
How is that even possible?
At the very least, we should be able to protect Eden's fear.
wait it seems a bit low i can bring it up again is it better or should i be louder
why did it give me rapunza i was a last minute sub so when um you know like someone that couldn't make it so the person that couldn't make it was rapunza so they gave me rapunza I
have failed.
I pray thy forgiveness.
Bring her inside for now.
Cecil.
So, this makes the third heretic you've let inside.
You have to bring it down when everyone's together again.
Okay, let me know when I have to bring it down.
The weapons developed
and it held up relatively well against the being.
Prithi, show us the way.
Find it yourself.
I'm busy.
Oh, we're busy for what?
I don't even know what you're doing.
I shall assist thee.
I bear ill tidings, young hero.
Out with it.
The maiden of thunder and the loquacious one shall verily join the fray.
What is he even doing?
He said he's busy.
Busy doing what?
He's just standing there.
Fire Dragon may verily join them as well.
It must be because of that signal that's similar to the calling signal the queen emitted earlier truly so Fine, I'll make the preparation.
Where is he?
Yeah, he does sound like him albeit slowly Tis simply for that she has sustained a grievous wound so formidable an adversary did she need?
me right now what happened
having beheld eden spear i humbly apologize by my own lips i cannot reveal the reason unless young lady marion herself chooses to disclose it i may not speak of it all right the queen's energy signature detected everyone prepare for bombardment oh no bombardment bombardment how much longer must we tarry You mean that thing's coming again?
Oh, no.
So you heard it too, huh?
Well, if we can't block this, Eden's totally screwed.
Uh-huh.
Can you really block it?
Okay.
I assume that...
Okay, okay, we're gonna go to the part where I found out I was a healer.
Wait, we're almost there.
Where the staff was like, okay, Doki, as the healer, I was like, me?
I'm like, you're like, you're like, sorry.
You'll understand.
I didn't even know who I was until I got to the recording, guys.
I didn't know what gave me to.
I was assigned.
If I knew, I would have looked her up.
No,
I thought I was like a magician.
I don't know.
I thought I knew magic.
I thought I was a whizzy.
Oh, no.
She's the strongest.
See, I told you she can take her.
All right.
The situation that's so dire.
There's not much else to do.
but to put our forces together and this is where i found out common cause of taking down the rapture queen are we ready to put it all on the line yeah yeah believe yeah oh my gosh oh falling comrades wait are you okay and then they were like cut okay joki um we're gonna have these falling comrades walk up to us and you're gonna be the one that you have to go up to them and heal them.
And then I was like, me?
Why me?
I was like, oh, because you're the healer, Doki.
I was like, I'm the healer?
That's what I found out.
Are you kidding?
It looks so good.
Oh, no.
Look at me.
here use this to pay for the hospital bills what if she's out of network she has Canadian health care oh wait oh wait I can also heal guys watch this is it working am I healing her
is it working guys oh my god
And she showed it!
Is it working?
I didn't play my earlier.
But, is she okay?
Don't worry.
I can heal this, guys.
Oh, no.
I know you can.
I can heal this.
No!
Power of money.
I'll pay your hospital bills.
I don't know if it didn't work, guys.
What the hell?
I'm sorry, I'm sorry everyone, the moment I was just so funny.
She's dying and you're laughing, don't you?
What the fuck?
She's dying.
I'm sorry, it was so funny.
This is just a moment.
We must use our reach.
Towards our meaning.
Enemy!
The rapture queen!
No more fallen comrades!
It ends here!
She's dying and you just throw money at her.
In the battlefield, there are only two kinds of people.
There was no script!
They were just like...
Yeah!
They were just like, they were just like, we're over the heel of them.
And I was like, okay.
against those clankers!
Yeah!
Oh yeah, Val was like, can I say clankers?
And they're like, yeah.
Okay!
Let's go!
We
wrote the script.
There was no script.
It was just vibes.
They were like, okay, so you're gonna fight these.
They were like, I told you guys, I told you the script!
It was literally like, okay, Joki, they're gonna like the Two people are gonna walk up to you and you're gonna heal them and I was like got it And I didn't even realize Bao was gonna do her whole monologue So I started laughing because I was not expecting it
It is literally I'm going through vibes and improv right now Hey
I mean,
that's true.
Why don't I just shoot the queen?
Oh, no, the support got a gun.
I'm going to have to start healing with my AK.
I'm dual wielding.
This is it.
also they were tanky as hell yeah I kept shooting at him and I was like why isn't he dying guys I wasn't missing too oh do I see that gangster style I need you You guys can see that.
I was doing gangster style.
It kept going!
Because you're- I didn't put enough XP in shooting apparently.
Cover me!
It's like five.
I was about to say that!
one pass jokie we're on the same wavelength it's like fireball batania that's what bullets are one more one more i said fireball
yeah surely that's the last wave guys right yeah they almost got him i don't think we can do better Wave 2!
I'm carrying guys!
Poor carry!
Now I'm a big boy!
He's gonna be next to it, sorry, just...
Okay!
Just... Rios!
There's no way I can get the big boy.
Vaden's!
Get good!
We're getting over, take it!
Back!
Stay quiet!
That's right!
Frontline support, Doki!
Frontline!
It's so intense.
I did not realize they were like, they were like right in front of me.
Look,
I wasn't last minute so, okay?
I wasn't last minute.
I didn't say his kiss.
I didn't like it.
Like, I was tied there for it.
Cut out.
I didn't.
I think they want something.
It's gonna be a while, guys.
I'm gonna get it.
Come on, come on.
Nope.
We were shooting for five minutes already.
I got tired.
Like we're shooting for five minutes and none of it was taking forever to die.
We didn't do our ammo.
I used all the ammo in the boss.
Everything that was done might have gotten stuck.
I'm taking out of it.
We're out of the avalanche.
We actually did it.
We're out of avalanche, everyone.
We did it!
Yay!
Take our skills to the final test.
To rebuild the Eden Spear.
With that, we can finally do it.
There was supposed to be five ways, but after two ways, we're like, we're going next, right?
Like, we're going to go to the next world, guys.
That's why I sat down.
We still have to rebuild the spear of Eden.
Oh, I think there's a really big piece over there.
That wasn't over.
Barely.
We should grab that.
We shall.
That made it.
Let's go grab that part.
Whoa, plus one RP.
Plus one.
Look, see, I stood back up, guys.
I'm standing again.
I love how she's just drifting.
There's no, like, feet animation.
Okay, ready?
We're ready to go.
She's rollerblading.
Oh, there it is.
Over here, hot potato.
Let's go.
Come on.
Oh,
okay, okay, I'm so funny.
God, I'm so funny.
Oh, it's gone.
Oh, no, it's there.
Oh, it's over there.
Good one, fast-dokie.
Why can't I be?
that funny all the time if you're recording joki is funnier than live joki right that's joki does it again
what a natural this is for you all right stephen you carry that i'll wait here all right
I'm my own I am I'm my own number one fan I have my the best dokey shrine Alan don't you remember I have the number one dokey shrine thank you for the super chat Alan thank you thank you she doesn't mean she has her other four senses that's
apart I mean I can do everything except peel I just throw money at the problem It has to be silver right because they're all silver parts We gotta find the last piece guys but maybe
it's not this way we don't know it was so hard to find and i remember we were struggling maybe it's the other way other maybe it's that way down over there yeah yeah maybe that way
yeah we're like where is it like i was so confused i could not see any silver part Oh, we weren't allowed, we couldn't split up because they want all of us together during this so that like, you know, like everything happens in one area, so we couldn't split up for it.
Plus one RP.
She was so good at role playing, guys.
I had to, I had to compliment her.
Plus one RP.
arms lift wait lift with your legs oh yes you got it yeah looks like a big pizza and so many good ones that's what i was here for i'm the one liner girl in this new game in the year do i still have it do you take it you take it yes you have it you have it's in front of me it's right
I'm the yeah, that's right.
I'm the comedic support
So like during this they were like okay when all of these are together the animation will start playing So we're like we're like why isn't it working Because they're like the staff was like when all of this is together Um the animation will literally start playing so like get ready.
So like okay like um who went to trade school guys i was just like what's going on i have a history to grade that i'm useless that's why you're a youtuber um so no hesitation no hesitation that's why you're a youtuber
It's so fast, Tokyo, another banger.
Can we even grab them?
No, we can't.
Yeah.
They're stuck.
Oh, shit.
Hmm.
So, uh, maybe we cast a magic spell or something.
Wait, if I was trying to cast a magic spell, just cast a magic spell.
Oh, shit.
Who knows the magic words?
shit all right okay we'll cast a spell you know i know one thing that we could always do what would that be guys what could it be
foreshadowing and it actually it worked
Okay, that was not planned.
I didn't think it would actually work.
I literally threw bunny and then the animation started playing.
I was not ready for that.
Fire and a spear.
Oh, that too.
But yeah, fire and a spear.
Wait, before, before, before we were like action, we were like as a girl, I was like, okay, I'm gonna say this and I'm gonna say that.
And then I'll go for, I'll be like, guys, I go first, right?
And then everyone was like, yeah, you say something first.
So I was like, okay, I say fire the spear.
And they're like, yeah.
And then like, and then 200 people started talking.
And I'm like, wait, I thought I say fire the spear.
So it was like right here.
Like, fire the spear.
Oh, that too.
But yeah, fire the spear.
We did it!
We're so good!
Oh my god, fireworks!
Oh my god!
That too!
The world, guys!
I told you!
Oh, this was one take!
We couldn't do retakes!
I just had to roll with it!
With the power of friendship!
And Nikkei!
Yes!
Maidens!
Yeah!
We finally celebrate the Nika third anniversary!
And the power of money too!
Thank you, Nika!
Yeah!
Amazing.
I think I did pretty well as a sub, guys.
As a last minute substitute.
What is your dailies, everyone?
What?
That's the last line!
That's the last thing you hear?
Are you okay?
I'll give you a lie.
Four things have happened.
Remember to do your dailies.
Niki, goddess of victory.
The part.
Don't forget your dailies.
these everyone we said oh they're so
happy remember to do your polls guys so beautiful guys
Remember to do your pause, everyone.
Remember to do your dailies.
I should have been like, hey everyone, remember to click the link pinned in our chats and remind us of a plus two sponsor.
I didn't realize that's the last line in the entire video.
to do your dailies.
God is a victory.
Niki.
But yes, honestly, I think I did so well as a last minute substitution into the sponsor because everyone else was apparently they were confirmed while, yo.
And, you know, I got plopped in.
Got my, got the briefing, like, the day before the recording, I think I did really well with what I was given.
I think I rolled with it really well, I guess.
I think I, like, added to the to the syn- to the Thetir, you know?
Like, I was- I had a lot of content to this.
Oh, I gotta say, I'm glad you're happy with your streaming job but anyway anyway if you guys i will say no wait i still have like a lot of stuff to tell you guys i have another i have a special video to show you guys that only i have um but uh guys if you uh um please feel free to click the link pinned in the chat or in the description below because it does help out the stream and the sponsor a lot but no i got like I got received from the staff who did the recording of all of this.
Because, like, all right, we'll finish watching this part because this is lore, guys.
This is very important lore.
This is what scripted stuff.
You're like, do this.
And this is the five.
And then, like, you're, and then we believe in you.
And I was like, that's not good, but okay.
I don't know if you should believe in me.
But you can tell that I was not like the...
I wasn't the role player in the group.
I was more of like the comedic relief.
This is the story of our journey.
Alright.
So, to give context of this recording.
So, when...
You guys saw the two girls that I healed that were not part of our group.
Like, who were they?
So they were additional actors from the staff.
And like, when they were like, okay, so our additional actors are going to go here to be these two characters.
And you're going to have to heal them, Doki.
And I was like, all right.
But we had to wait for, I don't know what we were waiting for.
But the staff had to like do something else.
So me and the two actors, we were chilling in the corner.
And then I was like, and I was like, oh, you guys have really good track.
Why don't you dance for me?
And...
So I was getting my own personal show.
You know, you know, foreshadowing, you know, Club Dokeybird.
He's getting my own personal show.
And that's when I learned about the money-throwing emoji.
that's where i figured out i could throw money at them because i was like wait i remember in vr chat you can like you can like send custom emojis out so while they were trying to give you a private show that i was like oh my god like i i i figured out vr tech um and so we didn't get that recorded so when all the recordings were done um i was like let's celebrate everyone and i was like come
I was like come and dance for me and this was like you know after the fireworks and I was allowed to show this when I asked them like they sent me the footage by the way they recorded it I didn't think okay if I was like are you gonna record it yeah I recorded this and I was just like um they sent they edited this and sent it to me and And so,
like, we were done, like, the fireworks and everything.
We're like, let's celebrate, everyone.
And, like, as a joke, I was like, come, dance for me.
Um.
It's like, that was the after Friday.
That was the, that was the, the after party of the recording, uh, running back, okay, okay.
They sent this to me.
I was like, whoa!
Okay, that's, that's what he needs doing, buddy.
Look at that.
Yeah, Cleo was just like, I'm here, I guess.
Very elaborate.
I got, that was, by the way, we were over time.
I would like to say that we were like overtime because like the recording was supposed to take two hours And then we went three hours overtime So I was like I better get my overtime pay and they're like we got something better And then so they so she started dancing um
Whoa, whoa, what was, so, yeah, I was the most, yeah, I better get some overtime, guys, um, yeah, and it's no one, too, so, um, but yes, the sponsor, the steps sent me the videos so i was allowed i was allowed to show it guys i was allowed to show it because it was it was a good overtime good overtime anyway put it i'll put it here let's see hold on i don't know okay so i have story time oh my god i don't even know where to what okay We'll put it here because I'm here.
All right.
So this is overtime back at headquarters.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'll tell you guys the story tab.
So basically I was like, I said like last week, I was like so stressed out.
And I was so stressed out.
And I was like so tired of everything.
And I was like, oh, I'll tell you all that you guys.
That's why I was like super late for...
I remember what I think it was where it was a Minecraft stream I was like late for the Minecraft stream um but basically like this like caused me to have sleep debt because it like built up because of the recording um so like I said I wasn't going to take the sponsor at first because there was only two days they're like okay so uh we really need like uh Ken Doki did this like uh we had someone that couldn't make it and the recording is in two days um and then I was no it's like it's all everything is in vr and i have nothing set up for vr by the way i had nothing because if you guys didn't know i like had to move suddenly so i didn't bring my base stations for those who don't know what the base stations are they're the things that you you like you that tracks you basically that tracks the the rest of the vr kit stuff so it like looks finds the headset and the trackers and everything and they have to be on the walls so like obviously I didn't bring it because like they were stuck on the
walls so like um there was no way for me to uh you know bring it to my new place like because I had to move suddenly so um no I have the vibe it's the newer headset but I have the vibe so basically um but then they were like you um here's your this would be the pay and I was like I can do it and then and I looked up Amazon I was like how long till the base station arrives and it was the next day so or it was like two days I was like oh that works yeah I can do it I can do it because they're like oh it is super last minute so we'll pay you this and I was like I was like um you don't have to say anymore I'm fine like so so um the thing is i i got everything i got the base station i even ordered a ladder because like i had to use a ladder to like stick the to like put the base stations on the the walls i got i even ordered a ladder too but when i got the base station i realized wait i have no mounts for it I have those like double-sided wall tapes.
So I was thinking I was just going to use that tape on the base station and then just stick it on the wall.
And then just like just that's just going to be it.
So I, silly me, I received the base stations.
This is what it is.
I put the tapes on.
And then I was like, all right, time to plug in the power.
And you see that little power knob thing on the bottom?
them left so i couldn't stick it on the wall because the power thing was poking out so so i was like oh and by the way this was on the day so i had three hours all right yeah right after the the harbour mania stream i had to do this i had to set everything up so because i got all my stuff on that day i received like my packages on that day so right after the the alice stream i was like okay i got everything i gotta set up so i had three to four i think i don't remember if it was four hours or three hours but i had three to four hours to set up all my vr stuff and so so i was like i got this okay i just got sticky on the wall so and i was like wait a minute i forgot to buy the wall mounts so i was padding panicking very hard because I was like,
oh fuck, I don't have, how am I supposed to perch these base stations on the wall if I don't have a mount?
And I was Googling, I was like, where do I buy wall mounts in my city?
And like, it was like, order on Amazon.
And I was like, obviously, I couldn't do that.
So, so there wasn't like a way to like, order it or buy it right now.
So, so in my head, I was like, wait, I have an audio foam.
So, what I did was I grabbed one of the audio foams that I still have left.
I taped the audio foam to the wall, base station.
Very dangerous, by the way.
I got on my ladder and I put the base station on top of the audio foam.
So I got one done.
Yeah, that looks so safe.
It's still up there, by the way.
It's actually still up there.
So then I was like, okay, now I gotta do the other side, the wall where my PC is like facing.
So like I'm looking at that wall, like the So the thing is, in my head, I was like, okay, this should also work, you know, like, you know, it's, it's the same, it's the same mechanic.
It's the same thing.
Like how, why would like, it should work?
Because it worked on the other side.
So I did it again.
I put the audio foam against the wall, and I put the other base station there as well.
But it was very dangerous because I was like, my table was blocking the ladder so I couldn't move the table in a way where I could fit um where I could fit my ladder so it was like already tilted and there was like a little tiny gap of where the ladder could go so I had to like get on the ladder and then lean my body weight onto the wall and then like i tried so hard to like put it on it was so scary like i had to lean forward and put my body weight on the wall so i could reach the top of the audio foam and then like and i was like i did it i fucking did it and then literally two minutes later it was like
because I was like, my base station, because they're $200 per station.
So I was like, why didn't it work?
I don't understand.
Why didn't it work?
It worked on the other side, and it's still working, but it's still taped up.
This picture, it's still there.
Like nothing has fallen.
So then I was like, why isn't it working?
Maybe I just need more tape.
So then I start taping it like crazy.
start taping it crazy on the foam I was like and it's gorilla tape by the way I I'm fucked after like whenever I do move out of here I don't know what I'm gonna do but it's gorilla tape so I just put more tape on on on the foam because I was like in my head like that's how it's gonna work if I put more tape on it it'll be stronger so then i did that and you know i did the dangerous ladder thing again i did the i did the dangerous ladder thing again and then i put the base station up i was like that's it we got it and then five to ten minutes later i hear it it fell down and then it chipped the wall It's not okay.
I'm glad my landlord doesn't know I'm a streamer.
It like doesn't know my channel.
It chipped the wall.
But I was panicking because I was like, I was so scared that my base station was broken, but it's still okay.
It's, it's, it was, it's still okay.
And there's like markings on the wall.
So, so you were thinking, what does the wall look like?
So this is what the
wall looked like with the tape and so my game theory is that I think because it's underneath the vent the hot air is like fucking with the tape so because of that um because of that the um it's this yeah it looks like lost i showed this picture to snuffy and it's like this looks like the lost comic but yeah i think it was like it was melting the tape and that's why it wasn't sticking so obviously it was not sticking to the foam so obviously i was freaking out because i think at that point i had i didn't even um because like you know before then i was like setting up on my VR headset and stuff trying to find all the cables and stuff like that.
They found and charging everything.
So I found like all the cables.
So I was freaking out because I think I had like one to two hours.
I think it was like one and a half hours left.
And I was like crying to my manager.
And I was like, why did I take this fancy?
Oh my God, I can't get it to work.
It's not sticking to my wall.
I showed him this photo.
I was like, it's not working.
I'm crying right now.
I don't know what to do.
And then I was just like, calm down.
We have plan B.
You just don't go in and track it.
I was like, no, it would look so weird if I'm on my,
no, I have to get this to work.
By the way, after, you know, obviously I fixed it because you guys can see I was in VR.
Like, obviously, but I'll tell you how I fixed it.
how i fixed it um i was i i did manage to get it where because you see me moving my hands and everything because when you're in desktop you know you're like you can tell when you someone's on desktop because they can't move anything um but anyway um after we this recording and everything was done uh my manager was like that's that picture was pretty funny what
he was like You know, that picture's pretty funny.
You gotta show it.
I was like, were you laughing while I was crying?
And then, um, oh my god.
Let me see if I can get, like, his exact, like, reply.
Um, um, oh my god, give me a sec.
I need a, I didn't feed him entirely, but now he's like, give me the rest of the food because he woke me up.
All right, give me a sec.
He got mad that I woke him up.
So now he's demanding.
He knows I don't feed the rest of the can.
So I can use it as like, you know, I can use it as like a bribe for later.
Because I don't want to give him more food.
Oh my God, where was it?
Uh, oh my God.
I won't give you like the exact quote.
Yeah, I was like, uh, I was like, he was like, make sure to show this picture on stream.
And then I was, and he was like, it's so fucking funny.
And I was like, wait, were you laughing at this one?
I was crying and sent you this photo.
Cause the context of me sending this photo was like, I was like, he was like, how's the setup going?
And I was like, I'm crying.
I'm fucking crying right now.
I think it's the face station up.
Look at this.
And then I sent out a photo.
And then I sent that photo.
And he's like, and then I was like, what are you laughing at this?
And I was crying.
And he was like, no, not at that moment, but after the recording was done, I was like, that was pretty funny photo.
pretty funny photo it's like once you're done recording yeah it's funny I was like
and then while I was fucking crying and trying to get my VR stuff set up this okay so understandably you guys know how I have I have like like dad's doggy bed next to me like in my room and like it's next to like my chair so um obviously during like all of this I had to throw the bed the doggy bed outside my room right because I was like I need the space so you know I threw it out of the room and then dad decided to to still sit there watching me so
So, while I was like, fucking crying, and like, it's like, what do I do?
I want my face station sick.
He was literally just sitting in the fucking doggy bed just looking at me.
He was just looking at me outside my room.
And then, and then.
the emotion I used it's not it was definitely not an emotional support doc and I was like what the fuck are you looking at and then he's just like was she okay
are you good bro are you good like just judging me while I was like freaking crying trying to figure out because I had like at that point I had like an hour left so I was freaking out um and he's just sitting there like watching all of this happen after I like threw his doggy bed outside my room he didn't fucking care it's like doggy bed is a doggy bed and and then okay so like my last resort i got a i got my microphone box because i still kept it and then i was so desperate i was like i don't know what to do and i slammed the box into that tape corner and then it worked i was like wait wait it works and you would see thinking what does that look like well it looks like this I just kept my microphone popped I just slammed it in the garden and I put my pay station on top of that and it works it was a happy accident
and the thing is it didn't work it worked but I'm so glad that like it stayed I'll put the picture of the tape because that one was the funniest but like I'm so glad that the tape like like it's stay there for the entire recording because the next day the box was gone
the next day the box and the base station was gone it it was it fell down so like thank god it like stayed up the entire recording um
It basically collapsed itself.
So it was like, but it happened the next day.
So thank God.
Because obviously, we went three hours overtime.
And because it was like three hours overtime, I like, you know, I went to bed right after.
It was like midnight, by the way, guys.
Because like, Stephanie and I also like hanged out afterwards a little bit.
Um, um, so like, Stephanie and I hanged out afterwards.
So at that point, it was like, at that point when I was off of V.
it was midnight I was and I've been trying to like catch up on my sleep debt ever since because of the entire day of that one day of me setting everything up and then trying to do the recording and everything like I was like I'm still trying to catch up my body is still trying to regain itself but now you know why the next day for my I was not a person.
I I was not I was not a person after that because I'm still recovering from from this.
No.
And but yeah, it also didn't help that I threw away my contact lenses the day I got the sponsor too.
So I had to like deal with my glasses as well.
I was there like couldn't everything was so blurry because I had to like fix my glasses every 10 minutes because it kept like smushing into my eye so because it's smushing to my eye it was like smudging my lenses so I had to like like you know like underneath my my headset I had to like wipe my my glasses and everything every time so so because I didn't have my I had my and it was my first time wearing glasses underneath my headset um uh but also what was really cute was that oh yeah by the way my full body um i had everything uh plugged and like charged and set up for full body tracking but full body did not work i was so sad i was like trying the only parts that worked for my full body um tracking was the waste that is it I think it's just cuz like I think it's because of my shoot my I like I like to call it the shoebox I like I think it's because of the fact that my base station was not mounted properly because like one side was a fucking box the other side was my audio foam so I
feel like it was not tracking very well yeah it was not working so well um Yeah, and then, okay, but yeah, and then like, you know, I was having a breakdown an hour before the recording.
I was literally bawling my eyes.
I would be like, why would it work?
And I got there and I was like, I'm okay now.
Like, it did not seem like I would cry.
Like, you know, during the recording, like the video footage, I was so, like, I seemed okay.
But literally an hour before the recording, I was like, I wouldn't work.
I can't, I can't get it to work.
Why did I take the sponsor?
and then i you know and then everything and then you know 5 p.m i was like i'm okay now i got into the world i was like hey everyone
i like i got into the vr chat room like hey guys i'm ready yes schedule cry that's why i couldn't read the briefing in time too because i got the briefing the day before the recording and obviously like you know i think the day before the recording.
I was also very tired.
So I went straight to sleep.
I don't remember what was streaming.
I remember I streamed something for a really long time.
But I went, I was so, I think it was like Batman, right?
So I went to sleep and I woke up and I had to do the Alice game and I had to set up for this.
So then luckily we didn't do the record.
The recording was delayed because they had to like import another model.
I think it was for Lumi.
Lumi had to add a model imported again.
So, um, so we were just waiting for that.
Um, and then because from that, I was just I was like, I was like, oh thank God, I have time to read the briefing.
I was like, and I was like, okay, I'm good now.
I'm good now.
Also, I was trying to remember how to move in VR because it was, you know, I haven't done VR in so long.
So you can tell like in the beginning of the recording, because we did it all like in order.
So like, it's not like in Hollywood, like, you know, in movies, they film scenes out of order.
So you can tell at the beginning, I didn't know what the fuck to do with my body Because I haven't done like VR chat in a long time Because like motion capture and VR is like different types of like It's different ways like you know motion capture is much more fluid You know,
you're just moving your body But in VR, you're holding controllers and stuff So it felt I'm trying to like figure out how to move myself And then as it went on, I've like I've got more I felt more like used to moving in VR and stuff But yeah, no that's that's basically the story of everything now you know now now you know that's why I was like no the setup leading to this sponsor was fucking crazy like um I'm not gonna see if there's anything else that I missed out on um but yeah no every oh yeah also like everyone else having technical issues and i was so happy because i was like yay it's not just me i mean it sucks for them that they're having technical issues but like i was like oh thank god i'm not the only one because like headsets were like breaking like we're breaking tracking was breaking as well so i was like oh thank god it's not just me i was so happy like during the filming of the the of the shooting scene,
I think like Cleo's headset died.
So she was just like standing man emoji.
And they were like, Cleo, Cleo, are you okay?
Like, it looked like she had like PTSD from the war.
Like, cause she was just like standing man emoji staring to the distance while we were like shooting these robots.
And like we had to, I think you guys don't notice it cause we cut it, I'm pretty sure it got cut out.
And we were just like, are you okay, Cleo?
And we're like waving our hands in front of her face and there was like no response.
And it looked like, you know, that, like, you know that like PTSD soldier, uh, image where he's just like, stares off the distance and like, you know, that drawing of the, the soldier with PTSD, the mild stare.
It basically looked like that.
We're like, are you okay?
And we're like, we should have like, we're like, we should have it in memoriam, like after this and me, like, Cleo.
because we're like if she can't come back and we have like an in memoriam like right after the wave and just cut to that and then like you know she can't come back it would make sense why she's not here like and yeah but luckily she was able to like like charge her headset during that time while we were waiting um so like we didn't have to do that uh but the really cute thing was that the recording um i think like everyone left except for like me and stuffy because we were we were getting ready to hang out and they're like oh can we get photos with you toky and it was really cute the staff asked for photos with me and what i took like i was on at that point i changed forms i changed back to croaky and then i was like i took photos with the staff as croaky like the people were recording everything um but yeah no it was really cute at the end so i took photos with them But yeah,
no, this is a really fun experience.
I've never had a spot do I never done sponsor like this.
So it was obviously, you know, especially like, you know, I had to sub in like super last minute too.
So it was a very fun experience.
I've never done it before, like, you know, doing like a VR chat, like acting thing.
Like I was so nervous, especially when, you know, I was just like a substitute too.
So like I didn't know exactly what we're doing.
I didn't even know the character I was playing until literally they were like, okay, Doki, since you're Rapunzel, you're going to have to heal them.
And I was like, I'm what?
Oh, I'm a support.
I didn't even know who I was until after during that scene where you're like, okay, it's time for you to heal them.
So, but I think I did pretty well.
I think I did pretty well.
And I think I, you know, highlighted the third year anniversary very well for Enike.
Thank you to Nike for sponsoring me.
I really appreciate it.
I had a great time doing the recording, despite me having a breakdown before the recording.
I think it was a fun experience.
Like there were some like technical issues throughout it, but I think like, you know, everyone did the best they could with what we had.
And, you know, it was my first time trying to, Like, you know, it was like one take, you know, so it was like my first time, like, I guess trying to roleplay this in one take, by the way.
And, um, and I had a, you know, like, even when we, um, and I got a lap dance too, so, for my overtime.
Technically, we all got the lap dance, guys, because they only sent that video to us, chat.
So we all got it together.
but hey you guys want to support the stream and support the sponsor uh feel free to click the link uh pinned in the chat and also in the description below it really does help out a lot and again thank you to nike for the sponsor happy third year anniversary everyone and like they say where is it like they say guys
Remember to do your dailies, guys.
Happy third year anniversary, everybody.
Okay, I'm going to head off now.
Thank you again for watching.
Tomorrow there will be a stream.
I think there's no rest day this week because there's a lot of stuff going on this week.
We are in the Street Fighter tournament.
So but that's the coaching for that starts on Tuesday.
I am trying to debate whether or not I play.
Oh, wait, I don't even wait.
I'm still in the sponsored part.
Sorry.
I don't know if I'm allowed to talk about it.
But other games.
But anyway, I guess like, yeah, this week is packed.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood.
blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everyone bye guys bye and remember everybody remember guys yeah remember to do your dailies